[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors depuis que ma tête ça a marché des
cas - ses deux cornes et c'est génial
j'ai découvert que quand il t'arrive
face à la face à la reine et tout ça tu
ne peux pas lui tourner le dos non mais
quand ton bureau est trop grand avec la
pièce alors que la personne qui bessard
- wells a fait ça mais ça ça s'éternise
500 cas comme une porte un moment ça ça
et l'autre côté nuit ça et c'est lui
sinon tu ne peux pas tourner le dos à
l'arrivée ça on ne touche pas la règne
on adresse pas la parole à la reine on
attend que ce soit elle qui vous adresse
à tout va et on ne tourne pas le dos non
une mi-temps mais j'aimerais que vous
fassiez tous pareil avec moi maintenant
et on a l'habitude de ne pas tourner
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive laurence à
rien et ça va réagir sur twitter de
coûts c'est génial j'ai conservé le même
luiz est ce que ça te le dire je me mets
une poule morte sur
[Applaudissements]
l'animal des cdg
c'est très beau
mais trois poils tout à l'heure que les
chevaux sont prisées comme ça donne à
voir une copie
que tu pourrais mettre des égouts des
trucs qui a des goûts 10 a pas de la rue
sinon où après naturelles ou à mon
époque je serai vieille dame qui était
sous un énorme car
si c'est trop chaud vous tapez vous
tapez 2 x martin si c'est trop chaud
j'avais tout événement le calme comme ça
j'adorais ouf on est là pour des choses
beaucoup plus sérieuses
donc meghan markle est en train de
détruire totalement la monarchie
anglaise pourquoi première question
arrive je serai ne rendra pas hommage à
son grand-père il va pas venir à la
messe le 29 mars en l'honneur du prince
philippe parce qu'il n'avait pas pu lors
d'obsèques et sa part est il que ces
meghan markle qui a empêché à ridelles
voir son grand père est paraît-il calé
il est tellement amoureux comme pour
l'instant il est complètement sous une
influence c'est vrai vous avez raison ce
serait elle en effet qui continue à
jouer de son influence maléfique sur
harry lui-même
dire qu'elle est en train de saper la
couronne vous avez fumé mathieu
meghan markle où on est une petite
actrice de province quand je ne vois pas
comment il pourrait saper la première
famille sur terre après dieu les windsor
je plaisante que pour elisabeth ii et le
clan rapproché désormais meghan markle
n'existe plus alors c'est regrettable
pour arrive il y avait énormément de
peine de la part d'eads isabelle de
surtout de ne pas voir harry aux
funérailles dans le fond le valeureux ce
qui va se passer c'est gmail officiel
souvenez vous quand on a enterré le
prince philippe s'est en pleine crise du
coffret nar c'était en tout petit d'un
joli thèse et au taux élevé seule
l'allemande est ici pour le coup 2000
invitations entre guillemets ont été
lancés toutes les cours européennes
venant réellement présente donc c'est
vraiment les funérailles officielles est
en effet le seul qui sera absent c'est
arrivé conscient que les gars a bien
aimé gagner là où ça devient
catastrophique c'est que la reine du
coup n'a encore jamais rencontré lille i
bet savoie yi et ça c'est encore à cause
de qui bah oui 2 mégas
oui mais voilà ils seront alors on
espère quand même que il faut savoir que
buckingham je me suis pas renseigné
buckingham avec tout le monde en offre
pour ce harry et mégane soit présent le
29 mars alors ça n'a pas été le cas
néanmoins buckingham n'a pas encore
renoncé totalement à la présence d'
harry et mégane au jubilé qui aura lieu
le 4 joie et ça va tomber la date
d'anniversaire de la petite élise est
pour le coup elle est né un 4 jeux sera
pas la
jsk williams peut essayer de convaincre
son frère ils ne se parlent plus il a vu
tout contact entre milliards nehari très
très peu voire pas du tout en tout cas
d'après les sources aussi team ont été
révélés des personnages se mettent wade
buisson un proche du clan windsor ce que
l'on peut dire c'est que cris et mégane
probablement vont être au moins 1 de
nars au mois de mars miss et ça c'est un
vrai homme de -12 9 mai excusez moi au
moins d'avril à charge
c'est cette manifestation qu'il a lancé
pour les personnes handicapées ce sera
entre le 16 et le 22 avril et
l'anniversaire de la reine temple va t
en ils seront ou à la haye aux pays bas
autre très belle monarchie d'ailleurs
donc il y à des vols entre la haie et
londres aux marcheurs 40 minutes non ah
oui lindsay owen jones pourrait y avoir
le jour de l'anniversaire de la reine le
20 avril en vol privé qui seraient
affrétés pour que mes
garçons qui les éduquent tous games et
non conforme des handicapés pour que du
coup ils se rejoignent c'est quand même
assez hallucinant merci mais alors
paraît-il que harry mégane veulent
revenir en angleterre mais oui en faut
aller en fait que dans cette fois time
et ils ont prolongé leur bail de leur
petit cottage à londres mais les vaches
tango mais non
achetées le 12 mars étudiants pavillon à
chaque marque et hatchback marre parce
que c'est un fait cette grenouille pour
le coup et qui qui appartient à la
couronne utili mis à la disposition de
la famille qui est mis à la disposition
contre moi y'a contre financement et
beaucoup traîné lyon restent égaux
pour ça qu'ils ont fait ça coûte quand
même des gamins millions de livres on
croyait qu'ils voient là le bail se
termine au mois d'avril et ils viennent
de le relancer ce qui veut donc dire que
il projette quand même de revenir et
pourquoi pas ce qu'il va quand même
d'accord en amérique ça ne se passe plus
rien du tout les contrats qu'ils ont
avec netflix et spotify la catastrophe
sinon il ya un flux de thunes plus on
est riche plus il faut de l'argent je
peux le dire quand on me dit tu sais
qu'on apprend t on à la première photo
de la reine tout amaigri
mais écoutez elle n'est pas mourant mais
va selon jeu donc on croise les doigts
et encore quand même allait bien j'étais
à londres le week-end dernier j'étais à
lyon le week-end dernier je me suis dit
j'étais sur le pont pourvu que london
bridge is not dard mon dieu oui mais oui
mais quand même c'est oui parce que là
il faut laisser le code c'est le jour
d'après nomura
alors il n'en fut incroyable à propos de
megan ta fameuse copine et bien figurez
vous la tenez vous bien parce qu ils se
diraient à ce qui se diraient et c'est
la soeur de mégane qui disent ça
soignez vous étiez le termite que
connaît aussi la demi soeur de vega ma
chérie le clou août a été c'est me dont
alors nous emmerde pas pour le moment
avec l'état tu vois des gens pillent
sans déconner
la demi soeur samantha écoutez bien ce
qu'elle à 10 elle dit que archie n'est
pas le fils de marie alice grieg déjà
elle est en fait sa demi soeur et la
tromperie de retrait
ils ont pris la plus belle de la porte
et il en photo la monarchie
n'y a ni je crois que la mère porteuse
n'a pas encore remis le bébé je pense
qu'une preuve d'accouchement de l'utérus
de masseur devrait rapporter si les
enfants doivent avoir un titre et archi
ne voit pas en avoir parce que je crois
qu'ils ont eu recours à une mère
porteuse dire que même sa propre famille
peut pas l'attaquer est ce quartier est
l'enfant de megan est arrivé
oui bah oui c'est qu'est ce qu'on a mais
parce que la demi-centre qui sera pas
roux et la ville début du mariage elle a
fait écrire le livre qu'il est
absolument scandaleux à propos du
mercato à l'époque où megan faisait
encore son job à la très peu fait mme à
l'époque elle le faisait encore dont
deux non non c'est vraiment en clans les
marqueurs qui met le club à niort faut
rentrer
maintenant on dit que c'est archi qui
sera peut être pas mais c'est harry qui
sera pas le père c'est pas faux bilal a
même dit que c'est lui qui est pas le
plll dit qu'il faudrait une preuve de
solidarité de kent
d'écouté façon à ce qu'on dit les
vérités trois secondes on va pas parler
que du physique
tant pis là je touche lâcher les chevaux
mais quand même elle est magnifique oui
elle sa amourachée d'un petit mec qui
ressemble pas à grand-chose tout ça nice
rennes ne me
serais pas israël charcutier à besançon
elle traite on arrose il serait pas
actrice américaine
les maires à l'état vu des millions mais
c'est quand même heureusement il n'a
jamais eu
des braves des rameaux mer c'est moi je
suis police rappelons quand même que
megan s'était marié une première avait
été demandée en mariage une première
fois et elle avait jeté sa petite bague
qu'elle avait fait renvoyer par la poste
est ce que ce sont des manières et marié
un producteur qu'il n'y a pas de boulot
et du coup elle a divorcé ils étaient
taxés de manière de cette coupe de
belhani s'il allait cesser dès manière
aussi je voudrais que le ton potache
n'est que de deux cas
[Applaudissements]
ils n'ont pas donné un
show d'israël mais rien du tout d'accord
mais
bon c'est happy days 2 secondes et punch
et dinard chenille la meuf elle a jamais
rien su
[Applaudissements]
elle est là pour avoir l'affairé des
médias du monde on n'est pas des sla
vraie obsession tu sais mais ça c'est de
faire de la politique non elle veut il
faut que tu es là jamais rien fait de ce
fait d'elle-même
lui qu'elles sont suisses
en étendant le clan windsor elle ne
pouvait pas faire de la politique qui ne
sont pas sexuée politique comme on dit
ils ne peuvent pas ils n'ont même pas le
droit de vote dont elle devait ressortir
que même quand il joue il se marre
avez-vous des données sensibles
me
bertrand becker ne pourra plus d'être un
seul pied aurait au minimum le comme
loin
il la déteste en angleterre médiane mais
il avait à bruxelles toute ta vie rémi
aussi dans le milieu des comédiens de la
déteste c'est d'actrice super populaire
et tout mais viennent c'est pas vrai
demandez vous plutôt c'est pas la
famille royale quartier tous et meghan
markle merci minorité mais elle
maltraite en personnel de maison dont
ils gagnent mais ça va donner c'est vrai
qu'ici vous aussi vous haïssez meghan
markle soyez les bienvenus